hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts phenotypic profiling for
improving drug discovery productivity
presented by dr. Ellenberg she is a
chief scientific officer of
translational biology at European
discover X I am Marjorie Torres of
Labatt's and I will be a moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational lab seminar
presented by lab use laberd's is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual event and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during this
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hear in the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom or center of your screen are used
to ask the question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window
involved a process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Ellenberg
I will now turn the presentation over to
her
thank you it's great to be here happy to
be speaking to you about my thoughts
about how we can improve drug discovery
productivity just one note about
conflicts of interest I am an employee
of urethanes discover X and I will be
talking about mentioning a little bit
about one of our a couple of our
platform technologies but most of this
presentation is certainly my opinions
and not necessarily the opinions of your
offense Discoverer X so if we start here
what I'm going to talk to you about
today is the crisis in pharmaceutical
productivity talk a little bit about
where we are with the current drug
discovery paradigm and what I see is
weaknesses in the paradigm and then
present to you some some of my thoughts
about solutions that are coming from
innovations in in new technologies
better models of disease in particular
in vitro models and advances coming from
combining in vitro and in silico methods
so everyone is probably familiar with
the pharmaceutical productivity crisis
certainly we know that our drug costs
are very high and one of the reasons
driving this is the fact that more than
90 percent of drugs that go into
clinical trials fail and they mostly
fail for época C or safety reasons so
obviously contributing to high drug
costs and and problems for both patients
as well as as companies and you know
despite all of our investments in omics
technologies genomics proteomics etc and
high triplet methods our success rates
have not been improving they're
stagnating and keep in mind that that we
completed the sequencing of the human
genome over 15 years ago so it's it's we
expect we anticipated being doing it
in nineteen 2018 then then we are with
with success rates in the clinic so if
we take a look at the current drug
discovery paradigm the typical target
based drug discovery paradigm where
where do I see the weaknesses so
typically targets come from genomics
they compounds are screened against
those targets and medicinal chemistry is
applied to optimize leads and they go
into preclinical animal testing and then
subsequently human testing so where I
see the the weaknesses in this paradigm
are our reliance on genomics derived
targets and also our dependence on
animal testing for making decisions and
determining whether or not we're going
to go forward with a program and go into
the clinic so the way I see the problem
with genomic is that we are suffering
from genomics addiction it's easy to get
a lot of data there's lots of cool tools
to visualize the data giving us what I
believe is an illusion of knowledge our
itch my issues with with genomics is
that typically the data are not in
context in terms of a cell type a
condition a patient organ disease stage
etc and also gene expression is inside
the cell so it's also pretty too far
from the action the outcome of what's
going to happen in a patient which is at
the level of the organ and organism so
think of genomics really as being
machine language whereas biology and
clinical outcomes are object-oriented
programming and so it's very hard to
predict from genomic information how a
the program is going to work and that's
one of one of the key weaknesses in our
current paradigm the second weakness I
see is dependence on animal models so
where the what's the problem with animal
models aren't they great models of
disease well the problem is our favorite
models usually typically rodents don't
live very long compared to us two years
versus 70 years they're very small
compared to compared to people and the
environments that they are housed in are
very clean very standardized and and not
do not contain a lot of the exposures
that people have in terms of from
viruses and bacteria and saliva from our
pets and our children so we are exposed
to quite a different environment than
animals in that are used in
pharmaceutical research this has huge
impacts on on some very important areas
of biology that are studied for drug
discovery in oncology does DNA repair
mechanisms if an organism is only only
has to live two years it doesn't need
much in terms of repairing DNA because
it's not going to be around long enough
for those collected mutations to cause
any harm whereas people live for so many
years they have to have a lot of
different mechanisms to take care of
mutation rates control of blood flow and
a very tiny organism isn't subject to
gravity as much as we
are the size of our blood vessels of
humans is much larger than in animals
and actually the distance of a tissue
cell the average distance of your tissue
cells from the closest vessel blood
vessel is much greater in people than it
is in in these and rodents and
particular mice so control of blood flow
and hemostasis is quite different
between humans and mice course
contributing to cardiovascular the
ability to predict how a cardiovascular
drug is going to work in a person and
most of all immune system status mice
and rodents their immune systems are
relatively naive they haven't been
exposed to many stressors bacteria and
viruses whereas people adults human
immune systems are quite differentiated
and activated and educated so they're
quite different our response to and
diseases such as autoimmune asthma
allergy the mechanisms are quite
different in people so these this is
some of these are some of the reasons
why depending on animal models to
determine whether or not a drug is going
to work into a person doesn't work so
well and those are just a few of the
areas where the differences in animals
and people makes makes up makes up makes
it problematic to discover drugs that
are going to work what we do need is a
mechanism or solution to incorporate the
context and complexity of human biology
into our drug discovery paradigm we need
to remember that we're take into account
build in the fact that biological
systems are modular and hierarchical so
no matter how much we understand about
how a drug interacts with a protein
target at the molecular level that does
not predict how that target will work in
a pathway how pathways might interact
and combine together in a Cell house
interact with tissues and so on and so
we have to incorporate higher levels of
organization in in our solution
solutions
so the way we do this is to think about
building better models of disease that
are human relevant that do incorporate
these these issues and be able to by by
combining in silico and in vitro
approaches work towards improving
prediction of drug action in people I
will say that in silico models alone
aren't the solution many in silico
models predictive models rely on
published literature and we have to
recognize that there's a known problem
with reproducibility in the scientific
literature there's a lot of poor quality
publications arising from misaligned
incentives and explosion in predatory
journals and there's also a persistent
bias coming from the fact that people
are much much more likely to publish
positive studies and negative studies
not to mention statistical
cherry-picking issues that that cause
problems with with taking in only
published literature in addition there
is a often misapplication of predictive
models there are many models that have
been published that are out there where
there's really been insufficient data
going into the models or overfitting so
that when you introduce new test data
they do not work very well there's a lot
of global models that are tend to be
trivial because particularly most models
of drug-induced liver injury yes they
work for a percentage of drugs and
compounds but it's not at the level to
be useful model perform useful model
performance and in this area needs to be
95 plus 99 percent accurate to be useful
because often the events that were
predicting are rare and
and very high performance is is needed
and typically you can only get that
level of performance when you go to
local models that are very specific I'll
talk a little bit more more about that
later so what do we
if we think about our our task here how
do we do a better job of predicting drug
action and people there is a role for
certainly a role for for better in vitro
models of disease because we can use
human cells so that it would be human
relevant there have been a lot of
advances in cell culture innovations for
being able to culture human cell types
that also techniques that allow us to
run assays and very high throughput with
a quality mindset so very reproducible
and robust in terms of their
physiological relevance we advocate
following the advisers phenotypic rule
of three where your most useful assay
will will employ the highest
physiologically relevant cell type that
you can work with using physiologically
relevant culture conditions and
selecting assay endpoints that are
proximal close to two clinical endpoints
so the most physiologically relevant
cell types there are to use in culture
remain human primary cells these are
culture taken out of normal or our
patients and immediately cultured and
used in assays they're not extensively
cultured unlike IPSC cells induced
pluripotent stem cells or other stem
cell derived cell types which must be
cultured for sometimes weeks and months
to differentiate these cells into their
adult counterparts
unlike cell lines primary cells are not
mutated and not long-lived and of course
co-cultures of different cell types
which would represent tissues would be
even more relevant be through the use of
human cells obviously the results can be
directly compared to human clinical
there's no concern about species
differences in using human primary cells
in terms of what to use for the most
relevant endpoints to measure in these
assays validated clinical biomarkers are
the best their disease relevant proteins
or metabolites they respond they're
associated with with clinical disease
and/or responses to drugs in particular
more useful proteins with B cell surface
or secreted proteins because or or
metabolites because these are the most
proximal to a clinical endpoint they
mediate communication between cells and
tissues so that there's a higher level
of the of the organ article organization
and our serve as a natural bridge
between in vitro and in vivo and the
third aspect here would be to appreciate
that there's a lot of biology to cover
and one would do that through using
developing multiple assays that would
tap into different aspects
of tissues or cell types or disease
settings and this is a represents here a
standard phenotypic gas a panel built
with human primary cells that's
commercially offered through your
offense Discoverer X that contains assay
systems that cover vascular biology
respiratory biology fibrosis and immune
and inflammatory responses and so by
using a panel of assays one can cover a
lot of diverse range of biology and the
the other important thing to do to have
a system that that can predict human
outcomes is to test it so by developing
a large reference database and testing
many many drugs experimental chemical
compounds tool compounds building
validating these assay systems for their
relevance testing their relevance for
for clinical biology so this is a way to
develop a a a tool or system that can
help us identify those those compounds
that might might do do better in in in
human clinical trials the ways that we
have to validate these systems then is
by by applying data mining right so we
for example here is a a set of data
across this particular panel of 12
systems shown in the top now we showing
here a list of several different drugs
along the y axis the x-axis represents
the clinical biomarkers that are
measured in each one of these assays so
in each system on order of you know 10
to 15 clinical biomarkers is measured
and what we can do then is by taking a
set of drugs one two and three drugs
that are and we can look across at these
biomarker activities and find common
activities that are shared by by drugs
for example these three drugs share even
though they aren't against different
targets and used for different
indications they share an adverse affect
and we can see that they share an
activity they all increase the the level
of a protein biomarker in one of the
systems that's shown by the the blue
indicates the protein biomarker level
has increased and the orange shows you
where protein biomarkers are decreased
and even though their overall patterns
are quite different between these two
three drugs they do share they share
this one activity in this assay
suggesting there's a potential
hypothesis that this could be related to
the side effect because that's the one
aspect that they share and so in this
way we can use these large data sets to
search for correlations between
biomarker activities and clinical
effects so I'm going to share with you
two case studies both having to do with
cardiovascular safety which is a long
interest of mine the first case and with
how we've applied these these systems to
validate assays for their application in
predicting human clinical outcomes the
first case study has to do with the
cardiovascular toxicity of oncology
drugs in particular related to traumatic
which is a mek kinase inhibitor that's
approved for and we can see that they
share an activity they all increase
and we can can neck neck kinase and the
second case study that I'm going to
present has to do with from both this
related side effects the prom Strongbow
cysts and pulmonary embolism so let's
begin with the first case study
tremendum is an allosteric mek inhibitor
which was approved for the treatment of
metastatic melanoma
like most oncology drugs it has side
effects these includes rash diarrhea and
cardio toxicity that I'm that I
mentioned so what we had identified with
this particular drug is a biomarker
signature in these assay panel that was
associated with terminal and other drugs
that are associated with that have
increased risk of cardiovascular
toxicity and this was increased levels
cell service levels of a protein called
serum amyloid a in a primary human
primary cell based assay of vascular
inflammation a coronary artery smooth
muscle cells and tremendous increases
the level of serum amyloid a added as
did a couple of other drugs that were
also known to have cardiovascular
toxicities and what what was
particularly interesting is serum
amyloid a is it's an acute phase
response protein but it's actually a
known clinical biomarker for vascular
inflammation and a risk factor itself
for cardiovascular events so this was
very encouraging suggesting the
association might be could certainly
potentially have have clinical relevance
but we went to confirm this we went
forward with studying
the how this particular protein was
regulated in this system and to
understand the positive and negative
regulators of this protein serum amyloid
a in our in vitro model and so what we
do is we take the profile so the
activity signature increased serum
amyloid a and run it through a reference
database of about 3800 drugs that had
been profiled in this assay system and
identified all of those drugs that also
shared this activity of increasing serum
amyloid a and I think it was a 40 or 50
drugs but was interesting and
experimental tool compounds what was
interesting is that they fell into some
very specific target classes and
mechanism classes MEK inhibitors like
term ethnic glucocorticoid receptor
agonist
these are glucocorticoids h dec
inhibitors aisle 6 pathway agonist
nicotine and and other modulators of
mitochondria in particular the ratio of
NAD+ to NADH so these were all these
mechanisms in caused increased serum
amyloid a in this in this in vitro model
then we went on to look at well what
decreases the level of serum amyloid a
in this particular model system so we
did the opposite data mining by
searching for those compounds that would
decrease the level and in this case we
came up with again a small number of
drugs and test agents but who fell into
very specific a small number of specific
classes a poi one mimetic glp-1 receptor
agonist a particular PDE for inhibitor
not the entire class which was
interesting and miss a proced own which
is a glucocorticoid antagonist as well
as various multi kinase
and inhibitors so a different set of
agents and but what was extremely
striking about these results is the fact
that all of the regulator's that
increase serum amyloid a has been
associated with increased cardiovascular
risk in people and all of the agents
that decreased serum amyloid a in our in
vitro model also were associated with
decreased risk of cardiovascular events
in people as well and so we got a very
tight and correlation between the the
level of expression of this particular
protein in this model system with with
risk for cardiovascular events in
patients and moreover these results
helped us connect multiple known risk
factors for cardiovascular disease we
know smoking stress and inflammation are
risk factors and comorbidities as well
as explaining how drug exposures may
impact our risk of cardiovascular events
too so we can separate these mechanisms
into those that promote cardiovascular
toxicity and patients and those that
actually support cardiovascular safety
and moreover when we when we put
together these mechanisms into a
hypothesis or how serum amyloid a is reg
is controlling cardiovascular risk
within the vascular wall we can we have
identified or developed a mechanism a
tissue mechanism for how this might work
that inflammation infection lead to
increased inflammatory mediators
including il-6 we get increased serum
amyloid
a it has serum amyloid a one of its main
activities is to actually suppress
monocyte recruitment and differentiation
into foam cells in the vascular wall so
so it it actually see remember when a
promotes the recruitment it suppresses
a suppressive mechanism so it promotes
recruitment and activation and
differentiation these differentiated
macrophages produce factors that drive
smooth muscle cell hyperplasia and
calcification of the of the vascular
wall which causes hypertension and again
the increased risk of events of
cardiovascular events due to due to
these this biology so this and then we
can see how serum amyloid a actually is
regulated by external mechanisms here
and therefore by applying this platform
this type of approach with panels of
assays identifying a predictive assay
through the use of a data mining a large
reference database we now at the end of
the day have a have a much more improved
understanding of the disease biology
which helps us you know of course not
only identify new drugs or more
efficacious drugs by keeping out of this
avoiding of this particular biology when
when needed but also helps us understand
how to manage patients and and clinical
trials because of the involvement of
environmental factors as well as the the
target of interest or for the for the
program okay so the now let me tell you
about a second case study about
thrombosis related side effects as you
know thrombosis is the process by which
blood coagulates in the in the vest that
vasculature and fourth clots very normal
part of wound healing but it also occurs
in pathologic settings like deep vein
thrombosis stroke and pulmonary embolism
and it's it's also a process in that
caused by Ebola which is actually a
consumptive coagulopathy because it
depletes all of the coagulation enzymes
causing coagulation once those enzymes
have been depleted leads to hemorrhage
so it's a very important biological
process in both health and and disease
so it's associated with exposure to
particular drugs as well as
environmental stimuli exposure to
smoking and pollution particularly
through polycyclic aromatic hydrocarbons
which are in pollution and cigarette
smoke exposure to contraceptives such as
selective estrogen receptor modulators
the firm's and various other drugs mTOR
inhibitors second-generation
antipsychotics and oncology drugs for
example Crisanta nib so it's caused by a
number of different drug types and and
as well as environmental exposures so a
few years ago we had identified similar
to the first case a biomarker signature
in one of these assay systems in this
particular case it was increased cell
surface levels of a protein called
tissue factor in a human primary
endothelial cell model system of the
vasculature this was identified this was
identified through a project that we
worked on with the Environmental
Protection Agency on the tox cast
program and published a few years ago
with Nicole Klein's Troyer and and Keith
how could the EPA among several other
other colleagues there so tissue factor
that protein was again quite interesting
because it is actually the primary
cellular initiator of blood coagulation
so a very suspicious finding is that
these some of these drugs and
environmental compounds that are known
to be associated with ROM BOCES related
side effects increase the level of this
particular protein in and definitely
so system so again we turn to data
mining to better understand the
regulation the mechanisms controlling
the tissue factor expression in this in
vitro system and doing the same process
by taking our signature increased level
of tissue factor comparing it to the
reference database which at the time was
smaller and identifying a number of
compounds but about less than I think
one percent of the or two percent of the
database but identifying these compounds
actually fell into a number of known
target classes which we were able to
place into a biological context and it
turns out that all of these mechanisms
are associated with the cellular process
of etapa G which is the way self eat
their own organelles and internal
internal components to generate energy
this is a important process it has been
targeted by oncology programs nerves
genitive to disease programs but in this
case this is a toff adji occurring in
vascular endothelial cells and so we've
identified that when endothelial cells
are undergoing this process they
increased levels of the vacuole ization
in cells is causing increased levels or
so tightly associated with increased
levels of tissue factor on the cell
surface and so again this process of
doing these testing across a large panel
of assays data mining a large
database of drugs and experimental tool
compounds that have known mechanisms
we've been able than here to uncover
much more detailed understanding of the
biology that's controlling this
particular outcome thrombosis related
side effects and connecting mechanisms
to each other so in summary for these
two examples that I've shared with you
certainly the use of this these these
approaches can generate results that are
very much more confidently can we can be
confidently confident in associating
them with the clinical outcomes moreover
it gives you a mechanism based
understanding and anytime there's
mechanism understanding it opens up all
kinds of orthogonal assays one can use
and generates new hypotheses for either
new drug targets or how we are going to
use drugs across space different patient
populations
so of course combining these in vitro
systems with the large reference
database is particularly about valuable
at identifying previously unappreciated
connections that help us understand the
disease but also in a practical way help
us be able to design better clinical
studies and stratify it stret stratified
stratify patients and keep in mind that
also this helps illuminate issues that
are going to show up in real real world
applications like I mean in real-world
therapeutic treatment of patients
because they have comorbidities they are
taking different in medications and are
in different environments and under
different stressors and so this gives
you a view into the clinical picture at
a very early stage so how might these
new approaches be applied or or be
integrated into our drug drug discovery
paradigm of course rather than than only
relying on genomics for targets we make
sure that they're either validated in
human phenotypic screens or or human
study human validated or even phenotypic
a seder I've hits so going to the
straight to an assay to identify lead
mater here both for for targets and
phenotypic assays it target using
structure based information one can
actually scream virtually screen
millions and billions of molecules
virtually which then can be tested in
and prioritized in phenotypic assays
then at the at the lead op and candidate
selection stage we can apply profiling
technologies such as the phenotypic
profiling I described to you but as
certainly all of the target based panels
that one can run there are many panels
kinase panels there are pharmacology
secondary pharmacology panels Surry Pez
many of these running a number of
companies offer access to to these
panels of assays and by combining these
with the reference data data databases
we can help identify those assays that
are most useful so again a role for for
virtual and silicon and silicon models
and once we have can use these
technologies to identify promising leads
and lead candidates they leads certainly
we now need to pay attention to exposure
so and we know in the exposure field
there's been a lot of work in developing
in vitro and in silico tools to predict
the absorption distribution metabolism
and elimination and so there's been a
lot of work in combining in vitro and in
silico approaches here and I will say
for this paradigm I'm showing here the
most the critical thing about the
predictive models in these cases is that
they are all local very focused on a
particular particular activity mechanism
based and with a large enough data set
to be and sufficiently high performance
of these models to be useful so it's a
series of both in silico and in vitro
models that would eventually I be able
to replace certainly replace animal
models I think we're only now
appreciating how poorly animal models
are at predicting human exposures and
human activities so the the advances in
in in vitro and Celico technologies they
don't have to be perfect to be better
than what we have today so if we take
all this date so another aspect of
having all of this in vitro and in
silico data is the need to have it
organized and I really like a framework
a framework such as this that for
organizing our data and our information
in in these outcome pathways these are
based a bit on the adverse outcome
pathway framework that is being applied
for chemical risk assessment in Europe
by
promoted by the OE and worked on by the
OECD certainly in collaboration here in
the United States with the US EPA and
NIH s this framework allows you to map
assays and data onto sort of an
organized framework of information
that's organized in the hierarchical
level which we know biology is organized
we can use the data to build predictive
models so it's a way to put organ put
collect data together all in a single
place and use those predictive models to
support decision making so this is a
framework that that would allow us to
make better use of all of the in vitro
and in silico data and tools that we
have by by putting them all together
into context so where's the field going
where the next important advances
happening definitely in increasing the
biological coverage there are new cell
types co-cultures and disease conditions
to be evaluated there's a lot of work in
advancing IPSC technology to get
additional cell types to be able to use
to compare patient patient cells and
stem cell technologies and then of
course there's the development of more
advanced cellular systems 3-dimensional
bioprinted tissues organs on a chip
micro physiological systems these are
still in being developed a lot of our MD
this is a very interesting area and we
we've seen some some cases case studies
examples of published on the development
and and the use of these systems to
to make make new discoveries and we look
forward to higher throughputs decreased
costs that would enable the the ability
to build a larger reference database for
example that remains to be done in the
future and of course keeping in mind
that a drug is only effective if it can
get to the target and so we still are
looking at still seeing advances
happening in the area of exposure
modeling that enable quantitative risk
assessment and risk is for toxicity but
also for predicting advocacy as well
that's that's a very important area of
research
that we're looking for advances to to
help us so with that I'd like to
conclude I have a final slide to
mentioned some of my certainly my team
here at eurofins it does take a village
and I've mentioned here a few
collaborators that we've worked with
over the years and also I want to
highlight some of the organizations and
agencies that are promoting non-animal
methods and helping to get these
technologies developed so these include
government agencies NIH FDA oacd as well
as as academic and private organizations
and I encourage you all to support these
these organizations who are actually
helping us take on the reproducibility
crisis are they
the productivity Krait and the
reproducibility crisis we hope to but
definitely the productivity crisis in
drug discovery
with that thank you and I'll turn it
back over
Thank You dr. Berg for that informative
presentation we've amassed at the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask the question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for that get started our first
question is what are the limitations of
the cell types used in these methods
okay there are a few limitations costs
can be a limitation and that's why scale
is important to keeping down costs there
is the donor variation donor variability
is is a limitation and so one has to
incorporate the analysis of donor
variation in these in these in these
model systems and an availability there
are many cell types that are simply not
available a lot of work going into those
pancreatic beta cells neurons
oligodendrocytes or some of the cell
types that we would love to have human
in vitro cell types model for
thank you our next question is how does
this work compared to the use of
cardiomyocytes for cardiotoxicity great
question most of the work with that
people are aware of with with
cardiomyocytes right now have to do with
arrhythmia
and so that is a whole other mechanism
of cardiovascular toxicity which is only
explains some of the cardiovascular
talks some of the drugs that have
cardiovascular toxicities due to eighth
arrhythmia problems and in that field
it's it's a little easier because there
are good clinical measures or reasonable
clinical measures of arrhythmia unless
it of course in the case of a new drug
for particular indication that they had
no reason to suspect that it might cause
arrhythmia causes causes that so that's
that's an area where there's a lot of
separate research going on but it
explains a particular mechanism of
cardiovascular toxicities and if you
notice that there are oncology drugs
that have the mechanisms that I talked
about today so it kind of explains why
it's been so hard to nail down
cardiovascular toxicity mechanisms
because there are many
for that answer my next question is when
will FDA start accepting non-animal
preclinical studies
so great question FDA will accept it now
how FDA works is they want you to show
that you've that your molecule is safe
and so everything that you put into a
package for an IND for example is to
answer that question in many drug
classes like biologics antibody
biologics for example you know may not
have a relevant species and DEA has been
open in the past to starting a clinical
trial with molecules typically at a very
very low dose to make you know - and
then do it through a dose escalation
they are open now but I would say that
it is a historical and legacy that is
driving the use of animal studies in in
clinical in drug development and it is
typically just the conservative mindset
is that if something goes wrong I've
done what we've always done I've done my
animal studies so I've covered my myself
and I think that is what's happening in
in drug development when the data is
convincing enough that we can replace
animal models so we need a lot of
examples right we need a lot of examples
where we would have identified
problematic compounds or made the same
decision as preclinical then these these
will be adopted it will take a lot of
data and an education
you
thank you okay we have time for one more
question our last question is has this
approach been successful for other
toxicities such as CNS or kidney
toxicity great question we have not done
any any work in this area there are a
lot of in vitro assays that are being
worked on for these for these tissue
types that have shown very interesting
results and and certainly encouraging
preliminary results but it takes the
ability to test a very large reference
dataset to fully validate an assay for
productivity and I think that still
remains to be done
I would like to once again thank dr.
Ellenberg for her presentation I would
also like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August of
2018 you'll receive an email from
laboratory know when this webcast will
be available for reply please read that
announcement for their colleagues who
might have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye